and you're talking about a va
that only serves 20 of the veteran
population
and they're the biggest healthcare and
they have millions and millions and
millions of dollars
and they won't give me four thousand
dollars over a year
because i asked them for help they deny
me
so do you think i i give a crap about
the va anymore
i think they suck they basically said no
yeah that seems extremely unfair next
time i fall into one of those depression
holes and if anybody's ever had
depression or anxiety or tbi or ptsd
or anything survivor's guilt and remorse
and all the other stuff
that i have wrapped up in stuff and it
goes in waves
and i hit one of them waves and now i'm
in a hole
and if i get nobody around checking me
nobody around i'm all alone
just sitting here and when i start
getting in that hole
i can't climb out of the hole to get a
hole gets deeper it gets worse
now i'm in the darkness now i don't
shower and a week and a half goes by
and i'm in a real deep hole it's really
hard to get out of it
and all i have is somebody saying well
just just buck off and man up
you should just wake up at 3am do a
thousand push-ups you suck you're the
biggest [ __ ] i ever met
you got that and you got somebody you're
going what dude i don't
and i got everything coming down on me
i'm going man i just i just
i just don't know what's wrong man i
can't i look at myself and i go man
i don't i don't know what's wrong i
don't know what's wrong with me man
and all i asked a va was i just i know
i'm in a spot
and i want somebody to help me with the
tools somebody who's educated
in some therapy and some other stuff
that when they start
when they start seeing me getting a
little bit of a hole before i start
digging deeper and i get worse
before i set student on it they go hey
man you just
hey try this out hey here's some tools
man here's some yoga
why don't you try this practice out why
don't you do that
and i go man that's a really good idea
i'm gonna try that they don't just tell
me i'm a
freaking wimp and i gotta man up or i
gotta do that or that and if va says
no we don't believe you because you come
in here and you look pretty happy
because you're seeing me on the day i
went to the va it's not the day after a
week and a half with no shower in a big
hole
you're not gonna ever see me when i'm in
my hole but when i got out of the hole
and i said hey look
i've been in a hole like this year it
happened five times
this year and i see it i see a pattern i
see some stuff going on
how long does it last for shoot one time
it was like a month and a half
oh my god and so i finally get out of
the hole and i'm talking to the vr and i
get out of hope on myself
because i start reading something or i
see something on social media because
i'm on social media i'm on my instagram
i'm on my instagram and somebody on
instagram says something they go hey
you know i've been there you know and
this is what and they tell me
just enough in one sentence on my
instagram and i see it it pops up
and so i say hey i just followed you
back because you follow me
and i pm to you what are you talking
about it's a personal message
so now we're talking we're talking
behind the scenes now
and i go what what do you mean by that
and i'm in hole man i'm deep
yeah and then they say well what i mean
by that is this and they gave me some
really good advice
as someone who's been there and i go
holy cow that's a really good idea
now i'm out of the hole a little bit and
i said what about this mist now i'm not
a little bit bit
and so i got out of the hole because i
had a whole bunch of my followers
who are on instagram who are on twitter
who are some facebook followers but
mostly instagram really helps
because i can see stuff and i see their
pictures i see where that
and the picture's a thousand words so i
see them all happy and i go and i said
man you're
like really happy with your hair you
know it's like mine i'm all like i'm
kind of ready i don't really look that
good
and you're like thinking about this
you're thinking about that and i look at
the pictures i see what they wrote and i
go damn that's kind of like me
because the picture says a lot what they
say says a lot so instagram was really
good for me
but then on the same instagram i had a
guy
who was a navy seal who i served with
who started totally giving me crap
and it made me whole words totally like
i was like man
why would they say that they knew who i
am they gave me a little secret little
snippet
that i know he was on my platoon i know
what platoon he is
i know who he is because he gave me
enough information
that i'm able to figure out who it was
but they gave me a lot of crap
i didn't deserve and then he did even
deeper he started sticking the knife in
even worse
and i was going man how do you know
where i am in life
right how do you know what's going on in
my life that now you stick a knife in
as a friend dude how do you know where i
am with a shotgun in my mouth getting
ready to pull the trigger
he could have been the one to pull the
trigger through an instagram post
by giving me all that crap but i hate by
the bigotry
you don't know where i'm in life why
would you do that to somebody
dude just be nice man give a help man
how about a hug
mug it's blind hate you don't have to
really self-hate somebody you don't know
where they are
so instagram is good because i see
pictures i see stuff going on and i see
that
you know what that guy the navy seal who
i know it was
has a hidden name has hidden pictures
you'll never figure out who he is by
name by fiction
he's he's anonymous so he's an anonymous
little wimpy dude
hiding behind a keyboard giving [ __ ] to
somebody
keyboard warrior little the most weak
weak mind weak person the weakest person
on earth is that person
because he has no strength or integrity
or honor
no you're gonna do that to somebody
behind a hidden war by a keyboard
warrior
you're gonna try to make somebody kill
themselves because you're so weak
the weakest person i've ever met is that
person well notice
in a in a category of very very weak
weak mind weak intellectual weak
spiritual
because you don't even have a spiritual
awakening where you can see this or see
that or
understand humanity is diverse we have a
lot of stuff going on
come on man how weak are you yeah i've
come to realize that the people that
leave those
toxic hateful comments on social media
they they
it's coming from a place of self-hate
they literally they have
the lives they're living they're so
unhappy and they're just projecting that
and trying to make themselves feel
better it's like a it's just it's toxic
and it's a cesspool if you're if you're
in that hole and you're in a deep hole
you want to do anything to try to get
out of that hole and that's alternative
therapies
so that's my non-profit it's called
mindful valor because valor
isn't thumb chesting valor isn't how
many push-ups or how tough you are
or the ufc doesn't valor
mindful valor is about mindfulness
mindful values about intellectual
integrity and honor and strength
mindful values about spiritual strength
mindfulvalor.org
is my non-profit okay so i get money
to pursue alternative therapies to try
to find alternative therapy
in any way dude if you live in
washington state and marijuana is legal
and if you smoke a joint and you're good
and you're able to cope or do whatever
you got to do
then you can pursue other things man
that's good therapy
if you live in new york like i do and
you start doing yoga
and something you can do and it works
for you man that's therapy that works
for you then get out of that hole
if you do like i have like a buddha
right there and i have
aromatherapy stuff going on i have my um
himalayan salt black which i heat up and
i burn and i have this
i have stuff i have like a 100 different
alternative therapies that i pursued
have you ever looked into you've got
only some places some of them are
illegal in other places
but the thing is like who are we to
judge the legality
of a god-grown plant that might help out
a lot of people then man you should be
able to do that man the law is related
and that
it's like and this is april 2020 april
20
man come on april 4th in 2020
man that's like the creator told me to
go smoke some herb
yeah on you know this week was it monday
this week man
i think the whole world should have been
stoned well the worst drugs
yeah the creator said april 4th 2020
everyone should smoke it up that was god
given right on a god-given day
that said everybody gets stoned yeah but
there's laws man
well who are your laws many of your laws
of man or laws of the creator
are they spiritual laws are they made
madness and when we apply to some apply
to others and what's up with the law
what's up with the law that only applies
to some people not others
i don't like those kind of laws if you
have a law that applies to black and not
white
if you have a law that applies to female
not male if you have a lot of applies to
someone who has this or that or that or
that
you're making up laws that apply to
being gay or straight
that's not a law man that's a that's a
bigoted way
to persecute one person over another
and those laws are illegal those laws
are illegal by
the laws of man and the laws of god
if they apply to one or not the other
one of my favorite comedians quotes is
the worst drugs for you are the ones
that aren't taxed have you ever
have you ever experimented with md
anything like mdma
for ptsd hug mug
i've experimented with you
now hugs are great i love hugs when it
comes to all that i have not yet
um tried that i'm trying to do more
study into some of that before i would
even do it myself
i don't know enough about it but i do
know other people have done it
i'm trying to get more information from
them okay
yeah i've heard a lot about it i've
heard a lot of really good things about
it
i've heard a lot of things yeah i've
also heard good things about shock
therapy
you know 1940s 1940s and 50s when they
stick to big things on there
and they send like 400 volts through
your brain
yeah in the old days in the old days
they did it was kind of like a
punishment it was kind of like it was it
was it was abuse it was
it was like criminal freaking torture
but there's been there's been some
advances in some studies
because we've learned so much that i
don't i know someone who did that the
other day
and i had had great great results
shock therapy shock therapy man the
old-fashioned like
like frankenstein shock therapy holy
[ __ ] that sounds brutal the advances
the advances it's not brutal at all it's
actually it's therapeutic
that's the thing is like if things are
done wrong it can be very very harmful
but if you do things i mean even
waterboarding man i mean you waterboard
somebody and it's like good it's good
for you you know you know you're only
waterboarding the right way you're kind
of not just kidding
yeah it's total torture sorry you to do
that part of your training right
yeah it hurts it's painful don't ever
get waterboarded it's really painful
but the thing is like there's a lot of
things that that
if you do it the wrong way you can
definitely harm people and there's ways
to do things that can be helpful
beneficial we just need to figure out
through science
and to experimentation and through uh
to be able to do something and and have
a repeatable
um solution of repeatable um
outcomes to the procedure
that are beneficial so if it's
beneficial to
90 people and 10 people it really hurts
we have to figure out what's going on
and
and we have to fix it went to find out
because you're harming 10 out of 10 out
of 100
that's it's not really it's not good
we have to figure out with drugs there's
a lot of drugs that are out there on the
market
that are legal but it also harms a
pretty big part of the population
if they're used incorrectly or you have
to use correctly but just for that
person
it would have a chemical imbalance or
chemical side effect
that's extremely harmful